a cada uno de los 51 cargos de asesinato
del primero al 51 se le condena a cadena
perpetua ordenó que cumpla las
sentencias sin libertad condicional la
sentencia es sin editar nueva zelanda
print on torrent un supremacista blanco
de 29 años pasará el resto de su vida
tras de las rejas
es un alivio para las víctimas y sus
seres queridos cuando salen de la sala
del tribunal no hay ningún castigo
traerá de vuelta a nuestros seres
queridos
respecto a guardias respetamos la
justicia la comunidad musulmana de nueva
zelanda y los no musulmanes por igual
nos mantenemos unidos contra el odio el
15 de marzo del 2019 este australiano
equipado con un arsenal de armas
automáticas abrió fuego sucesivamente en
dos mezquitas durante la masacre el
asesino filmó y transmitió en vivo por
facebook las imágenes del atentado
después de negarse el autor finalmente
se declaró culpable en los últimos tres
días los testigos han subido al estrado
uno tras otro
vértice repetidamente a las mujeres que
rezaran en silencio ya que temía que el
pistolero nos oyera y nos encontrará en
el almacén me mantuve en esa posición
hasta que la policía entró y nos dejó
salir del edificio de un ataque que
conmocionó profundamente a nueva zelanda
y sacó a la luz la existencia de un
movimiento de extrema derecha activo en
el país
y el trauma del 15 de marzo no se cura
fácilmente pero hoy espero que sea el
último día en el que tengamos una razón
para escuchar o pronunciar el nombre del
terrorista que está detrás de responder
es la primera vez que un hombre es
condenado por un acto terrorista en el
país la vigilancia de los grupos de
supremacistas blancos se ha
intensificado desde el año pasado